Carrie Underwood beaming over baby
number two it's definitely different
than the first time and when they say
every pregnancy is different it really
is just different symptoms and I feel
like I'm not like I feel like this was
just a little harder on my body for some
reason but it's really good and you know
we're just squeezing myself into
whatever two-second squeeze myself he
says he won't change any poopy diapers
though he doesn't yeah I understand
maybe I can change his mind we have
picked out a name we're keeping that to
ourselves right now but we're we're
fixing a move I haven't bought anything
yet we still have some of the stuff that
you know doing stuff like that from from
my son but yeah I mean we're just we'll
figure it out I'm like we're we're about
to move so I'm like I'll start buying
stuff once we're there it'd be pointless
to Maya and then move it one thing's for
sure pregnancy looks terrific on Carrie
the proud mama stepped out in this
sequin may need rest by Tadashi Shoji
for the 2018 CMT Artists of the Year
event this year they decided to honor
only ladies in country music it's just a
wonderful statement I think tonight is
just gonna be a fun night I think we're
gonna see some of the best talent that
this particular show has ever seen all
on one stage together not just because
we're women but because everybody here
is amazed
so and you're kind of continuing to
leave
well we started talking about we wanted
to take out on the road with us and you
know it's like checklist right it's like
who do I respect as artists and
musicians you know whose stuff am i
listening to who do I think you know the
fans would enjoy like seeing and it's
kind of like the smaller and smaller the
list got it was kind of like women on
there and and I was like okay maybe this
is just meant to be and so yeah we're
we're taking run away June and Maddie
and Tay a out on the road with us and
we're doing something special on stage
tonight honoring it's always it's
interesting when it's like somebody's
gonna go up there and like sing your
songs to you or you can go sing your own
or something and I'm like this is like
about women and it's not just about us
cuz there's so many women that came
before us that allow us to do what we do
they open doors for us so it was so hard
coming up with which songs we were gonna
do and I had like like 15 songs in there
and there was just the craziest medley
ever and we had to take some out and I
was so sad but it's it's just ends up
being just a great powerful moment I
think on stage
[Music]